[Music]
Applause from some of the 50 000
mourners as Pope Benedict's coffin is
carried into Saint Peter's Square
[Music]
and a cry from the crowd Santos subito
or Saint now calling for the
beatification the former head of the
Catholic Church who died at the age of
95.
Benedict stepped down in 2013 citing
poor health the first pope in more than
600 years to resign his success at Pope
Francis who came to know him well prayed
for him on Thursday
gracious father we commend to your mercy
Pope Emeritus Benedict whom you made
successor of Peter and Shepherd of the
church a Fearless preacher of your word
and a faithful minister of the Divine
Mysteries
clearly this wasn't on the same scale as
the last papal funeral in 2005 when John
Paul II died still 200 000 people came
to view Benedict's body lying in state
at Saint Peter's Basilica before this
public ceremony and many here
appreciated being able to say farewell I
think it represents a lot about his life
and what he expected a simple
celebration but very beautiful
despite having other things to do today
I felt that I had to come here I told
myself I had to come and attend Holy
Mass to accompany him in prayer
the current pope is now 86 he said he'll
step down if his health stops him
performing the role and the vatican's
foreign secretary recently hinted that
Pope Benedict's death could make that
path easier it was already very
complicated having two men wearing white
in the Vatican if Pope Francis had
resigned while Benedict was still alive
it would have had two former popes and
one reigning Pope Pope Benedict Was
revered as a theologian by many
Catholics but by his own admission he
was a leader who failed to act
decisively enough on cases of sexual
abuse by clerics his legacy is long and
complex Nadeem Baba Al Jazeera